black widow snags
80 million dollars from its theatrical
debut
60 million from disney plus folks let me
read that to you one more time
black widow okay out of the 80 million
60 million is from disney plus black
widow has stolen the pandemic era box
office crown the latest marvel film
scored 80 million dollars at the
domestic box office during its debut
the most of any film released in the
wake of covet
epidemic over the weekend around 81 of
the theaters were open to the public
according to the data of comscore
universal's f9 fast and furious 9 was
the previous record holder
getting 70 million over his three-day
launch into theaters last month
the film garnered an additional 60
million dollars from disney plus sales
in addition to black widow tallied 78
million from international ticket sales
here's what this means let me tell you
why actors are no longer scared
of hollywood here's why um
this is not the typical movie
you know hollywood thing that you're
doing netflix is coming right now they
want oscars they want academies they
want
grant they want uh whatever it is that
whatever they're giving away the awards
for best movies
actors are sitting there saying listen
man hollywood those days have a handful
of you guys having all the power in the
world they can't push us around you
can't do that anymore
you don't have that kind of authority
anymore the days where weinstein pre me
too movement
the days where weinstein had everybody
like stronghold and everybody strong
arm and everybody you can't do that
anymore today so hollywood actors are
feeling a little bit more
confident and liberated hollywood for
the longest time was almost a
dictatorship today
yesterday i come i get back to the
office i was in urban land
i come to the office first thing in the
morning you know what's sitting on my
table right now you know what's sitting
on my desk right now a script
a guy sends me a message saying i love
what you're talking about i got a script
for you
i'd love for you to invest into our
script or buy your script from us
sitting over there
we're starting to get more scripts than
ever before what does this mean person
can have money one ten million fifty
million twenty five million dollars i'm
gonna do a movie here you go
and then you can go pitch it to who
others rather than going and selling you
to traditional hollywood
route so i think the ashton kutchers of
the world and all these other guys are
getting comfortable because you're
seeing what happened with the black
widow movie
all right is this the plus is this it's
a statement no need to go to the movie
theater is it essentially becoming
almost like a cryptocurrency type of
decentralized platform it's not just in
hollywood anymore
you got it's a great disney plus you've
got netflix you got amazon you got the
you can go down the whole freaking list
and the hulu's in the distance that's
actually great
and it's just not decentralized now the
the harvey weinsteins of the world to
use your analogy don't control hollywood
anymore well
the studio is a great thing for a lot of
people it's the studios that don't
control hollywood anymore and by the way
barry diller one of the legends who ran
two of them what paramount
and uh universal i think he said last
week that
the movie business is dead he literally
set out he said the
going to the theater experience the
movie business is dead
and it's never coming i agree with him i
100 agree with him and you know
never netflix doesn't release streaming
figures like this disney
to say 60 million that that's uncommon
for them to actually
release that but that's unbelievable i
would never go to a movie theater again
i don't think i have no upside to going
to with you
who's got the time for it what movie did
i watch i don't know didn't you go to a
movie theater i mean if i take the kids
oh we watch fast
faster than a few years ago i gave it a
seven it was actually a good movie
you gave the nine a seven no i give the
nine a seven okay i give the nine to
seven i took the kids i hate when that
happens
i go home with a nine or you wake up at
the seven i accidentally took the kids
to mortal kombat
i accidentally took the kiss to mortal
kombat
till today yeah there's not a day when i
bring up movies where they don't bring
up mortal kombat what do they say well
you're the one that took us to mortal
kombat the worst movie of all time
i said i've taken you to 50 movies
you've loved one of them
and the last thing we need is dylan and
tico fighting we know we saw what
happened earlier
they had one of the most epic fights of
all time in aruba and yeah here's what
happened the fight i'm not going to tell
you the details of the fight but they
had a pretty big fight because
dylan through san antiko's face
accidentally apparently accidentally
i wasn't there to witness that mario was
so i walk up because mario's like you
got to come here to the beach dylan's
running off it's pretty epic crazy
stuff's going on with these guys
and you got to realize the robots are
very calm place the water has no waves
like literally there's no waves where we
are at the ritz carlton resort
i walk up and i go to the kids i'm
walking back this husband and wife good
looking couple in their 50s right
that kind of takes care of themselves
you know she's wearing a two-piece he's
got the whole nice six-pack
they said you're not gonna tell you we
love your boys i said really tell me why
it says
for the last hour all we've been
following is what your boys have been
doing
your two sons we can tell those two are
your sons but the other two are not your
sons right i said no why
this is because the other two are two
nights
and he says for one hour straight we've
been following them and we love what
they're doing the fighting the awards
all that stuff thank you so much for
giving us entertainment i said well they
they'll take 100 tip from you anyway so
we had a good time out there with them
back to the uh so they they they will
not let them they will not mortal combat
is done that's not gonna happen
real quick just a couple a little thing
to add you talking about the movie
studios paramount
and um universal and universal but
wasn't it didn't amazon just buy mgm
yeah okay so that i mean there's another
further example they did it just for
more content in their library
here here's how i don't i don't go to
the movie theaters like period i think
the last one i went to was like i took
my ex-girl to go see
winnie the pooh like back in the like
three years ago and be honest who were
you dating
otherwise yeah she was 25 but you know
she probably acted like she was five
however
this is how out of touch i am by the way
no she's not like she's listening she
dm's me
she's got me blocking she's got me
blocked um
this is how memories
what was the best part of winnie the
pooh when he got his head stuck in the
honey jar okay
you got your hand called the cookie jar
anyway here's how to
how did you're a high roller when you
take your girl to a winnie the pooh yeah
hey by the way
you know today's thank you for the
immortal comments yes i'm actually going
to pray more on completely different
food than on movie time by the way that
story yeah it actually gets you closer
to soul boy than further away
you know here's my point let me finish
my point and then i'm going to uh
this is how out of touch i am with
movies when i when i hear this story
black widow grosses 80 million dollars
i'm thinking oh they came out with
like
the female version of the black panther
then i look it up and it's freaking
white girl scarlett johansson the black
widow i'm surprised that's not cancelled
culture yet
yeah i'm just telling you stop it i
don't give a i'm just saying i'm
surprised that there's people out there
being like black widow
white ass scarlett johansson what the
hell is going on folks if you're
listening to this adam's not right
adam thinks adam thinks if you don't
know this already or not adam thinks
fast and the furious is a continuation
of knight rider
that's how old him
kidding me david hasselhoff i loved it
by the way you should show the poster
you have in your office of david
hasselhoff of knight rider they should
see it
i don't think people really say that's
not the night writer it's the baywatch
it's the baywatch one david hasselhoff
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye